Indeed from the greatest of the
blessings of Allah upon the servant is
that Allah
allows him to establish his worship and
his dhikr in houses that were raised for
the purpose of worshipping Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Allah mentions fi
buyutin adhin Allahu an turfa' wa
yudhkaru fiha ismuhu yusabbihu lahu fiha
bil ghuduwwi wal asal rijalun la
tulhihim tijaratun wala bay'un an
dhikrillahi wa iqamis salati wa itais
zakati yakhafuna yawman tataqallabu
fihil qulubu wal absar
In houses that Allah
has given permission to be raised and
that his mention occurs within them.
People glorify him in the morning and in
the evening or afternoon, rijal, men who
are not deterred and not turned away by
trade or by transactions and by buying
and selling from the remembrance of
Allah and from the establishment of
salah and from giving the zakah. They
fear a day wherein the hearts and the
sight will be overturned. This ayah
establishes the fact that Allah
is the one that has permitted for the
houses of Allah to be raised and that
these then are from the greatest of the
blessings of Allah. I come to you today
with an urgent appeal and it is an
appeal on behalf of our brothers there
in Dar us Sunnah in West London. Some of
you may be aware that our brothers have
been given a notice of eviction. They
have to leave the masjid very quickly,
very soon. And I know that it is
it is no doubt something that brings
sadness to the heart that one of the
best of the masajid of the people of
Sunnah in London
wherein shahadas are taken, wherein the
rules are delivered, wherein people are
taught and educated, that Allah Azza wa
Jalla has decreed that it should be shut
down. And so, Ikhwan, we come to you
today with an urgent appeal that our
brothers there that they need ayyuha
Ikhwa our support and our help. By the
virtue of Allah Azza wa Jalla though,
they have found another building. It is
a building that is bigger than the
previous building, and it is more apt,
and it is better placed for them to
establish it as a house of Allah Azza wa
Jalla. And they are currently at work
establishing that.
Ayyuha Ikhwa, these houses are houses of
Allah. They are not cafes. They are not
halls. They are not community centers.
But they are places where people make
sujud and ruku, where the dhikr of Allah
Azza wa Jalla takes place, where the
book of Allah is taught,
where the knowledge of the Sunnah and
Hadith is studied. And so, this then is
a plea, Ikhwan, for help for our
brothers. And by Allah, this may be
today one of the most important
announcements that you will hear, since
it is an announcement that brings to you
khair.
It is an announcement and an
encouragement for that which will
establish good for you and for your
families.
Whether you live in London or not, our
aiding our brothers there will bring
nothing but khair to the one who
participates in the affair. The masjid,
Ikhwan, must be
evacuated within a few weeks. And so, it
will no longer exist. For those of you
who have visited the masjid, and those
of you who have benefited from it, then
this masjid, Ikhwan,
will now be a thing of the past and that
is not metaphorically, physically it
will no longer exist. The landlord
chooses to turn the building now into I
believe some apartments and so
the masjid will no longer exist. And so
with this being the case
and with our brothers having to evacuate
with no extension, no negotiation
and no delay that therefore means that
our brothers need to establish the
Jumu'ah. They need to establish Tarawih,
the lessons and the Tahfeedh of the
Quran for our children
will no longer exist. That then is no
doubt something that brings sadness to
the heart. You know of the Shahadas and
the amount of individuals have entered
Islam with our brothers there at Dar
us-Sunnah. You know how many people have
been educated. How many people have been
rectified? How many people have returned
to the Sunnah? How many people have
found Allah Azzawajal and have found the
deen of Allah Azzawajal in this masjid.
And so this is not just a community
center. This is a masjid Ikhwan that has
had established within it nothing but
guidance and khair. And so we then
ask our brothers and our sisters. The
brothers and sisters from you may be
some who were married in the masjid.
From you may be some who had family
reconciliation
within the masjid. Some of you may have
shed tears within the masjid. Some of
your children may have memorized Fatiha
for the first time within the masjid and
some of you
may
have had the establishment
of yani the Jana'iz or
yani the prayers over our deceased
within the masjid. And so a huge part of
the community is going to be
disappearing. And so, that which we
encourage our brothers and our sisters
with and remind them of is the statement
of the messenger of Allah
that whomsoever builds a masjid for
Allah then Allah
will build for him a house in Jannah.
That
is a house that far surpasses anything
that exists here within the dunya. And
so, we encourage our brothers
contribute. Contribute with whatever you
can. Contribute with any
amount of money that you have and that
you are able. And for indeed the one who
contributes, he will have or this will
bring baraka to him, baraka to his
wealth. Giving in the sake of Allah
as the prophet mentioned in hadith qudsi
that Allah has said, "Anfiq ibn Adam,
unfiq alayk." Give, oh son of Adam, and
I will give to you. Give, and it doesn't
matter how much.
It could be 10 pounds, 50 pounds, 100
pounds, 500 pounds, 1,000, 5,000. Give
for indeed this affair is a matter of
urgency. As we mentioned, our brothers
are establishing
the new or
building within the new place. It
requires funds to establish. It requires
initial payments. All of these things,
there is no one that is funding our
brothers. As is the case with the
brothers and the people of Sunnah up and
down the country and outside of the
country, in the states and elsewhere.
There's no one that is funding them or
giving them money. It is by
the sweat of the brows of the community
that these masajid are established. And
so, let us then participate. Let us
participate in this great act of khair.
An act that will bring to you and return
to you in good in this dunya and in the
akhirah. May Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
give you all yaqum to my way of Allah
when I will
and you
have one and you have
three daughters in the sunnah
of Nabawi
and
you have one and you have one and you
have one and you have one and you have
one and you have one and you have one
and you have one and you have one and
you have one and you have one and you
have one and you have one and you have
one and you have one and you have one
and you have one and you have one